[Music]
okay welcome back my fourth of July
present is that I get to be on a hit
with Brian Ross who was our chief
investigative correspondent here at the
long crime Network the best in the
business and he knows all things about
Eddie Gallagher the Navy SEAL that was
on trial for war crimes who was found
not guilty but for a small minor offense
Brian tell us about this case it's
fascinating
absolutely Bob gonna have to do to you
this is a case being filed all the way
to the White House at one point
President Trump suggested he might
pardon Eddie Gallagher if he was found
guilty and in the last hour the
president has tweeted his
congratulations to Gallagher and his
family and said essentially I'm glad I
could help
we have no idea what it meant what help
he gave for that's what the president
has said meantime special operations
chief Gallagher is taking a victory
round this morning after what was really
a complete and total victory for him and
his lawyers and he appeared on Fox News
to thank everyone for their help you
know they tried to frame me as a
criminal from the get-go but you know we
knew the truth the whole time we knew I
was innocent of these charges the whole
time and I overcame it by having my
strong wife with me the whole time and
my legal team next is just spending as
much time as I can with my family and
friends and all the people that
supported me you know I plan on just
doing what every American should be
doing on the 4th of July barbecue and
having beers and watching the fireworks
it sounds like a good plan what made
this case so unusual was the tight-knit
code of silence that maintains inside
the navy seals was broken with four
members of the Gallagher's platoon
essentially testifying against him
alleging he had killed one captured
teenage Isis terrorist and randomly shot
at innocent civilians his lawyer Tim
Paula Torre acknowledged she was highly
unusual but told me in an interview
before the trial began he planned to
take these witnesses apart something
that you're going to see be seeing more
of as we have the generational gap
between these younger seals who
think that they know better than the
older more experienced leadership and
just because they can't get what they
want they feel like they need to go in
and make false complaints so you're
saying they're lying actually I I am
I'm absolutely saying that they're lying
I'm looking forward to cross-examining
them you know these are you they're
supposed to be our nation's elite
warriors and yet I look at NCI as videos
of them crying as they're telling
stories that then when you pull out the
video of the actual event they're
clearly lying about so I can't wait to
get these guys on the stand and you're
gonna take them apart you say absolutely
absolutely we intend to annihilate the
government's case and he did just that
it took the jury of all members of the
service all combat veterans just eight
hours to come up with the verdict the
only thing that Gallagher was found
guilty of was posing with a corpse and
he held the man's head in his hand and
then tweeted I did this one with a
hunting knife Bob yeah Brian
I mean this was a fascinating case and
that lawyer boy he he's right out in
front he and he did exactly what he said
he was gonna do but Brian could he tell
our audience a little bit about this
surprise testimony that occurs in court
when the government brings on a witness
that turns out to be the person he says
from the stand I'm the reason why one of
those victims died which shocked the
prosecution and I've read this right
Brian his answers to why he never told
anyone before was that he said I was
never asked if that's true what a ball
dropped by the prosecutors absolutely
and there a lot of questions about that
in fact they suggested they might
prosecute this Navy medic for perjury
saying he never told the story before
but essentially he said I'm the one who
killed this teenage Isis terrorist
because I put my hand or my thumb over
his breathing tube and cut off his
oxygen and asphyxiated Gallagher he said
had stabbed this person in the neck or
the chest several times even so beside
that testimony Gallagher was found a not
guilty even of attempted murder
yeah Brian I know that when that
testimony came out - there was a
question whether the prosecutors would
dismiss the charge against Gallagher but
they went on a theory that either don't
believe the guy who testified or he
still was the mean
cause of the death I did not buy it
obviously so what's up for him next is
he added the military is he honored
dishonorably discharged the what happens
here well underway now as we speak is
the sentencing aspect of the trial the
jury actually will decide the sentence
normally the charge of posing with the
corpse
is about a four-month sentence he's
already spent seven months in custody so
he's probably his time served he could
still face though a dishonorable
discharge or some kind of discharge that
is not honorable I would say his career
as a Navy SEAL is definitely over but it
does as you say also raised questions
about the ability of the prosecutors
here the lead prosecutor was kicked off
the case by the judge when it turned out
that he had put some sort of tracking
device on emails sent to Gallagher's
lawyer so he can see what they were
doing what they were responding and
because of that the military judge
kicked the lawyer off the case and the
prosecution really was hamstrung
throughout you know with this
prosecutorial issues that you've got
going on here I'm wondering whether
anything's gonna happen to those folks
you know we've got to stop having
prosecutors feeling they can do whatever
they want whenever they want and I was
one for most of my career and I ran an
agency and if anyone ever did something
like that to communications with a
defense lawyer I would consider bringing
charges against them
well Gallagher's lawyer has said just
that Bob he's demanded there'd be a full
investigation and criminal charges are
brought against the Jag the prosecutors
in the military you know another thing
Brian that I always loved when I watch
these cases and being a criminal defense
lawyer now are those that support you
when you're going through the difficult
times now he had a rough relationship
with many of the people in his platoon
which is probably obvious by the fact
that they testified against them but his
wife was there and very vocal throughout
all this and nothing like having a good
woman behind you when you're standing in
a trial for murder
well he had his wife he had his brother
and he had the President of the United
States and he had Fox News which made
this a quite a campaign which presumably
is where President Trump first became
aware of the case Brian last question
for you real quick what do you think the
odds are that I think the phrase used by
the lawyer if a pardon drops out of the
sky with regards to the one charge he
was convicted of doesn't this make it
easier for the President to pardon him
for this offense as opposed to obviously
murder that's a good question how
no the president what he's going to do
he did ask for the papers be sent from
the pardon office to the White House no
action yet whether this will be seen as
some sort of compromise justice served
we'll have to find out Brian are you
more of a hamburger or hotdog I I'm more
of a hotdog guy okay I like them both
anyway Brian Ross thank you so much as
always have a great holiday it was great
being on with you my friend okay guys
Brian Ross he's the best we're gonna
take a quick break we'll be back with
more law crime he get the chatroom
wouldn't you like better than hamburgers
of the hotdogs or like meat bulb we'll
get back
[Music]
[Music]